hi everyone this is International master
David proofs for chess calm and today
I'm going to teach you how to attack one
of the most basic strategies of all in
chess right attacking there's attacking
there's defending there's waiting around
attacking obviously the preference of
most chess players including myself so
when you want to attack you're going to
need to know two things to be a
successful attacker one is that your
attacks would be some more successful if
you pick the right time and place so you
don't want to strike at the wrong time
and basically the simplest way to know
whether or not it's justified or a good
idea to attack is comparing the number
of attackers and defenders in a certain
area of the board that's it you just say
you know right now I've got five
attackers he's got two defenders I'm
going to go for it or right now I've got
three attackers and he's got three
defenders so I'm going to wait and bring
in some more pieces if you can bring in
three more pieces and he can't bring in
more pieces then you'll be able to go
for an attack once you get up to you
know five or six pieces against three in
the area so that's the most important
thing and it's just that simple now I'm
going to show you two other things so
these advices that are going to follow
will help you to be successful with your
attack one of them is that it's useful
to have a target when you attack and I
will show you that with one quick game
right here so we're going to blaze
through it and you're going to see an
example of the game where somebody
successfully attacks because they pick a
target for their attack so here we go
blazing through you see that right away
black has some preconditions for a king
site attack because they've got more
pieces that can get to the Kings side
than white so here they start focusing
on the target which is g2 and they can
aim a lot of pieces there particularly
they're cleaning their Bishop and their
pawn so white sets up a defense to g2
and black keeps coming after it
sacrifices the bishop and brings the
knight to attack g2 as well white takes
the pawn and black gets his third piece
attacking the g2 square and this kind of
focused attack where all his pieces aim
at the same square allows black to win
this game by
checkmate here if the Queen is taken the
knight comes to h3 and otherwise the
Queen will just come to g2 next move
with checkmate
all right now the second thing that can
help you attack is to have open lines so
here's an example and the first
condition for an attack has been met
White has more pieces that are developed
and in position to fight than black
because black has three pieces here
they're really not well placed for
attacking or defending white can pretty
easily bring out his last piece at will
so it helps for white to have a target
or focus here and the first target or
focus is f7 which the Queen and rook are
aiming at but the other thing White's
going to do here that's really important
is why it's going to open up lines which
is just going to increase the power of
all of White's potential attacking
pieces so watch what white does white
makes a trade there Bishop was attacked
and now plays 'if I've happily
sacrificing both white central pawns in
order to open up more space for all the
white pieces and white falls with a
queen check and then bringing the rook
into the center of course if you ever
want to win a chess game you need to be
able to calculate something and the key
thing that White has calculated is that
the black queen can't stay in the center
to defend because this would trap her
that was the one key tactical point in
this game so anyway the black queen
moved out of the center and now you see
white sort of focusing in on these
squares on the F file as he attacks and
now it's just mopping up just a little
calculation to checkmate the black King
and with these open lines you see that
the white pieces are very very very
powerful and that is checkmate in one
move so you should be ready to attack
now I hope you enjoyed this video and
I'll see you around on chess calm